[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rosen the
executive director here at the long now
foundation and we are starting our 13th
season of these talks thank you all for
coming for the last 13 years and I just
wanted couple acknowledgments one of
them is to you all as members you fund a
huge portion of this series and that's a
not only that but you know general
operations of the foundation which has
been a huge help all the way through the
years but also Margaret and will Hurst
who fund all the video production that
gets done of these and the audio so that
we can put them out and about 1.2
million views we got in the last year so
it's well we have you know we've got 700
people here in the in the audience
there's another million people over the
course of the year that really get to
see these talks because of that which is
great and then our seminar sponsors who
who also fund a huge chunk of this so
it's these these venues and these events
are are difficult to put on as you might
imagine and our speakers all speak for
for free they waive their speaking fee
which has been amazing and so they're
also in a sense a sponsor of this series
so all of that put together is the
reason we keep on being able to do this
over the years
okay our speaker tonight and proud to
say has proven to be completely wrong
about something which is I've been
saying for years that most interesting
point in the society or civilization is
where invention becomes innovation sort
of starts to get put to use and I've
long said there's a pre-commercial
period that's really loose and you know
you're not trying to make a bottom line
you're just goofing around with the new
thing whatever it may be and that's the
most creative period except the kind of
stuff that are speaking or night talks
about does get commercialized right away
sometimes it's already commercialized
and then it gets weird and
it turns out the equivalent of being
pre-commercial as being frivolous and
that's why we love hearing from that
great scholar if we're good ideas come
from Steven Johnson hey thank you
it's such a great pleasure to be here
what an incredible waste of this amazing
acoustic space to fill it with my voice
I I'm so sorry to do this to you welcome
to 2017 everyone or 0 2017 as we like to
call it in the long now foundation good
and riddance to 2016 to get us out of
the the dread of 2016 I propose for you
an evening of wonder and delight that's
my plan for tonight now I was thinking
about this talk the other day I'd kind
of planned it all out and I realized
that most of the stories that I want to
share with you tonight take place over
the last thousand years or so which I
realized its kind of shamefully short
term thinking for the long now
foundation and I was just embarrassed to
come with such a short attention span
kind of view of history and so I thought
I would set the stage tonight with with
three objects that actually belong to a
much kind of deeper older historical
timescale and the first of these are
these shell beads found in Morocco
dating back more than 80,000 years they
were believed to have been strung
together as a form of a necklace and
they they're considered to be among a
few other kind of rivals the the oldest
evidence of jewelry and ornamentation
that's been crafted by human hands
80,000 years ago second these bone
flutes more than 50,000 years old
discovered in modern-day Slovenia not
far from the ancestral
homeland of Melania Trump hey there what
are the oldest bone flutes are some of
the oldest known musical technologies
crafted drums are a little bit older but
these are crafted to create a very
distinct pitch and in fact we believe
that some of these bone flutes were
designed to create musical intervals
that modern Western ears would recognize
as fifths and octaves as well those are
about 50,000 years old and then finally
a discovery from little more recently
from the old Babylonian site of Turki
where archaeologists discovered the
remnants of cloves that were dated back
to 1700 BC almost 4,000 years old now it
may not seem surprising to us that
Babylonian foodies had a taste for spice
in their meals but consider this until
just about 250 years ago every single
clove consumed anywhere on the planet
originated in one of five islands a few
hundred miles east of Indonesia the
spikes islands of lore so these cloves
four thousand years ago in Turkey had
somehow in an age where modern
cartography modern compasses modern
shipbuilding had not really been
invented yet these cloves and the signal
of interest in the taste of these
clothes had been kind of loud enough to
cause them to travel across a kind of
relay network of traders to make it from
these remote islands all the way to
Turki when people in ancient Babylon
would have had no idea of the existence
of Indonesia much less these five remote
islands and yet somehow these spices
made it all the way around the world to
arrive their beads necklaces flutes
spices so what do all these things have
in common
yeah let's start really with it with the
kind of a negative definition here these
are all things that we don't really need
they don't have a clear kind of survival
function they're not directly
utilitarian we don't need them to
reproduce we don't need them to keep our
bodies regulated at the proper
temperatures we don't need them to to
stay alive but we find them interesting
for some reason we find them delightful
for some reason and that history of
delight and that history of wonder is a
very ancient part of what it means to be
human and I in some ways in thinking
about this category and in this part of
our history I wanted to kind of do a
shout out to a long now founder Brian
Eno who came up with the everything that
I'm going to talk about tonight
basically falls under this umbrella of
this this definition that the Brian came
up for art which is art is everything
that you don't have to do that we don't
have to do we have to regulate our body
temperatures around 98 degrees some of
us at least have to reproduce to keep
any of the species going but there is a
whole world of seemingly frivolous
things that are part of our experience
and then have been apparently part of
the human experience for tens of
thousands of years that are nonetheless
incredibly productive and important to
our civilization and of course the
history of that I mean in in in this
work I tend to talk about these things
under the umbrella of a slightly
different word not not art but play
drawing upon a hoisin Goods notion of
Homo Luden's the man the player but it
basically means anything whether it's
games whether it's fashion whether it's
music whether it's whatever the
experience is it's something that is not
directly functional but that nonetheless
kind of activates our interest in our
surprise and our sense of delight in the
world now that the history of these
pursuits as trivial as they might seem
sometimes is an interesting history in
and of itself there is there's a lot to
be said about it
balls a lot of interesting characters
but I want to make a stronger argument
to you tonight I want to make a stronger
argument and and try and convince you
that in fact these forms of delight
these forms of play have actually been
significant drivers of change and of
progress in society if you think back to
the history classes that you took when
you were in high school or in college
and you kind of rolled off the list of
the prime movers of history that you
know kind of your surveys were organized
around you could probably do this on you
know the fingers of two hands right you
think about the quest for power or
various forms of tribalism or or
nationalism or religious beliefs or the
kind of long march of freedom or
democracy or scientific breakthroughs
that drove progress or the desire to
accumulate wealth all of these things
are obviously a huge part of the history
of human civilization but I would argue
that there is a another form of our
culture or form of our kind of human
identity that deserves a place in that
Pantheon that has been driving change
that has not just been some kind of
surplus that we got to enjoy once we you
know reached a certain level of economic
wealth and civilization but it's
actually something that made that
progress and made that civilization
possible in the first place
and tonight I want to talk about kind of
three major forces globalization
innovation and democratization and show
you how play and delight played an
integral role in making those things
possible now globalization of course
we've already seen it to some extent in
the story of those spices and those
clothes the the spice trade starting
with clove and nutmeg and cinnamon in it
and then pepper this is really the very
origins of a global marketplace in the
first place we have global economies
originally because of spices now this is
something that is taught in schools
right we hear about the spice trade we
hear about the age of exploration being
partially driven by spices and
eventually of course spices did become
somewhat functional seemingly sin that
they were rumored to have great
medicinal value and they became symbols
of status but it began that whole
process of forming a global economy of
connecting
parts of the world that would never
actually physically see each other but
would nonetheless share flavors and and
tastes it began with something as
trivial and frivolous as a spice is a
taste of a clove on the tip of your
tongue and in fact we are still living
in many ways in in the map that was
first carved out or charted out by the
kind of intrigue with with spices so the
first globally integrated spice trading
network was the Muslim spice trade
network that formed in there kind of 800
to 900 we had a single integrated system
that traveled from as far away as
Indonesia all the way to Africa we still
live with the after image of that map
because the map today of global Islam is
the map of all the places where Muslim
spice traders successfully sold people
these obscure spices from around the
world everywhere where Islam tried to
bring this religion to a new culture
through military forces he basically
failed but where the spice traders did
their work successfully
that's where Islam resides today in fact
there's an argument that Islam would not
have become a global religion had the
spice traders not brought the word
through their networks but there are
other examples of the way that the light
and play led to globalization and one of
them starts in the late sixteen hundreds
in London when a group of largely kind
of well-to-do women begin to be
extremely interested in this new fabric
that has come over from India really two
fabrics calico and chimps and these were
fabrics that had been basically
technology innovation that had been
created in the in India by dyers and
textile producers hundreds and hundreds
of years before that and they've all two
real breakthroughs one of which was
cotton itself which was kind of a
miraculous thing you know up until this
point people in England were wearing
wool underwear all the time which you
imagine and kind of damp rainy on a
night like tonight walking around with
wool underwear it was it was a little
bit unpleasant but the other thing that
the calico and Qin's brought were these
beautiful dyes and
and patterns that would survive multiple
washes so not only were they were
particularly vibrant and glorious to
look at but they were also durable and
so you could continue to enjoy these
these colors and and fabrics for for
long periods of time but people put them
on their furniture and then built drapes
out of them but then they started
putting them on their bodies and when
they did this the delight in this new
experience in this new fashion set off a
chain of events that transform the world
what first started happened is this
massive trade imbalance develops with
India the East India Company begins
making a vast amount of money selling
import and calico and chintz from India
and selling it to these well-to-do women
and what almost immediately then happens
is that there's a massive backlash
against these women because of course in
their fashion choices they are
devastating the traditional wool
industries of northern England and so
what you might call a make England's
wool industry great movement erupts and
these women who have developed this kind
of scandalous taste for these exotic
foreign fabrics and that are destroying
their national economy through this
interest in this exotic thing from
somewhere around the world begin to be
publicly shamed and condemned in a whole
series of pamphlets and poems and plays
and songs are written I love the idea of
you know political protest in poetry and
song I suppose that's what hip-hop is in
some level but they are they were
written about these women they were
called calico Madame's and it was this
kind of strange mix of nationalist
economic fervor and some weird misogyny
about these women who were indulging in
these kind of sensual delights at the at
the cost of of England's economic
well-being and for a while calico and
chintz were outright banned this is a
recurring theme you see on this again
and again people kind of developed this
interesting new delightful experience
and people just trying to outlaw it
because it's clearly destroying
everything and so for a while there it's
actually banned from from from England
and of course at the same time
separate group of people begin to look
at this phenomena and they say well wait
a second hold on what if we tried to
make some of these fabrics ourselves
using new technology using new
steam-powered technologies and machines
and that of course is the birth of the
Industrial Revolution and so the
conventional way that we tell this story
about industrialization is really a
story about these inventors and
entrepreneurs and people coming together
with these big visions of how these new
machines are gonna change the world and
they invent them and that eventually
creates an upper-middle-class its
wealthy enough to start to enjoy things
like fancy fabrics and and fashions and
grand department stores of the 19th
century but that story really
fundamentally has it wrong yes those
entrepreneurs and those inventors were
part of the story an important part of
this story but the spark that set the
whole process in motion or at least one
of the very key kind of defining initial
forces the prime movers it started that
whole process was this moment of delight
and wonder at a new fabric coming from
somewhere across the world that was
really the the beginning of the process
and it set the whole thing in motion
through that initial moment of of
delight and then you get to this you
know kind of very interesting process
where as more and more through the 1700s
fashion starts to accelerate and what it
started talked about kind of long-term
thinking what it started at the
beginning of the 1700s where the rhythms
of fashion were basically that a new
look would arrive every decade that was
basically the pace of fashion change and
then all of a sudden this new thing
starts to happen where cities around the
world begin to be coordinated in this
new kind of interesting clock on visual
looks that would be updated first once
every 10 years and once every five years
until by the end of the 1700s and you
could see this thing speeding up over
the course of that century finally it
kind of settles on this pace of you know
there's a new look a new mode every year
and that's pretty much where it where it
ended and and for a long period of time
people were very scandalized by this
accelerating rate of change and they
were also scandalized by the fact that
for the first time
middle and upper class upper middle
class women were able to kind of dress
and look like the elites and there was
this big question about whether this was
going to lead to a decline in the kind
of the natural order of society and that
the kind of hierarchies of society would
be basically unraveled because people
could no longer kind of distinguish
themselves visually between their kind
of aristocracy and the and the middle
class of the upper-middle class and in
fact there may be some argument that
this was in fact happening and the great
historian Brad l has made the argument
that while fashion sometimes seems
trivial it's interesting to note that
many of the cities many of the nation's
where democracies and political
revolutions first took place where
places where fashion were particularly
developed and then a sense you exercise
this interest as a society in new things
you have an openness to new experiences
you have a willingness to kind of shed
the look of the past which then maybe
creates the the groundwork for more
serious substantial revolution certainly
it it transformed the kind of semiotics
of class distinction that suddenly it
was possible for kind of middle class
and upper middle class people to look
like the elite and then eventually you
get these department stores in Paris and
in other great cities in the nineteenth
century and one of the things that
happens with the rise of the that kind
of grand magazines like the ball marche
is that this extraordinary development
development happens where well-to-do
women going into these grand department
stores begin to steal they arrive in
these places that have been kind of
designed to be these great palaces of
consumption and they even though they
can absolutely afford the goods on
display there they start stealing from
these stores this rash of kleptomania
runs through Paris it becomes known as
the department store disease and it sets
off again a really interesting kind of
intellectual discussion and scientific
discussion psychological discussion
about what is happening in the minds of
these people they clearly can afford the
goods they're stealing why are they
stealing it and what eventually the kind
of experts come around to is this idea
which is now very kind of custom in our
society which is that the bill to
environment of the store seemed to be
making people crazy and it was suddenly
possible to say well listen this was a
disorder that wasn't coming from some
you know problem that you could diagnose
with phrenology or you know some
intrinsic problem with hysteria or
whatever it was something about the
external world and changes in kind of
technology and commercialism whatever
was was making people a little nuts and
we live in kind of the echo of that
diagnosis today all the time when we
debate what you know the effect modern
media is having on our brains or fake
news on Facebook or whatever the
conversation is that was one of the
first places where we began to think
about the impact of kind of new
environments whether they're real or
virtual or the kind of strange simulated
Fantasyland Wonderland of a shopping
environment what that was actually doing
to our psyche so all of these things
come out of this initial interest in in
fashion something that seems so trivial
that ends up being so important now
there are other examples of both
globalization and innovation coming
together around play there was a an
extraordinary institution in Baghdad at
the height of the islamic renaissance
about 700 800 a.d baghdad at that point
most you probably know was arguably the
most advanced city in the world it had
incredible science and incredible
technological feats that kind of lamps
everywhere and running water and all
these things that certainly weren't
happening in europe at the time and
inside a baghdad at this point there was
an institution called or the wonderful
name called the house of wisdom and the
house of wisdom was in modern terms it
was kind of a combination of a
translation bureau and a think tank and
a kind of a maker lab and in it there
were people kind of working on
translating keeping these translations
alive of strange and Greek and Roman
Roman text which is an important part of
the kind of they were basically the
lifeboat for a lot of these ideas that
kept them in circulation and until
Europe got through its dark ages but
there were also a number of engineers
working inside the House of Wisdom
coming up with all these really
breathtaking advances in engineering and
they published a number of these works
they have great titles like the book of
ingenious devices and the there there
was a set of brothers now known it's
like kind of ban who moosa who published
some of these books and they're
beautiful books they only have these
kind of gorgeous illustrations and in it
there are very detailed engineering
schematics that at the time are some of
the most advanced engineering the world
has ever seen they have these float
valves and various hydraulic systems and
and they have clocks that are more
accurate than any clocks that europe
would see for another five hundred years
and they're and they're all detailed in
the in these schematics with incredible
precision with descriptions of how all
these various different technologies
work but what's interesting is if you
flip through the pages of these of these
books and look at these images what you
realize is they're all toys they're
almost none of them have any real
function there's a little kind of
animated elephant clock and little
automatons and little men who pop out it
with a little dish of soap and kind of
peacocks where the feathers kind of
flopping everything is is really
indistinguishable from child's play
and yet they contain within them some of
the most advanced engineering that the
world has ever seen and one of their
devices which was actually almost lost
to history but was discovered in a
separate manuscript about a hundred
years ago which may have been their most
significant man invention was was this
device called the instrument that plays
itself sounds a little dirty I realize
and what this was was basically it was a
back to our kind of bone flutes it was
it was an automated flute player this is
a reconstruction of it that there was
none a couple years ago in Germany and
it was technically really an organ
there's what kind of water powered organ
but it could be used with an automaton
to kind of create the illusion of
playing a flute and what made this
device so radical in such an
extraordinary breakthrough is that you
could control the melody played by the
device with
this rotating cylinder with little pins
in it like the the pins of a music-box
cylinder that most of us have seen and
the real breakthrough was that that
cylinder was swappable so you could take
it out code a new cylinder with new
instructions for the notes he wanted to
play put it back in and the machine
would play a completely different song
and the battle moose who were very clear
that this was a major breakthrough they
therein and there could've long
description of the device they spend
many many pages describing how you make
these cylinders they actually the
language they used was they basically
described them as cutting the cylinder
which is actually quite a bit like
cutting a record as we used to say back
in the days of vinyl and this was an
extraordinary idea for the first time we
have a machine that whose function is in
a sense open-ended where if you want the
machine to do something else you create
a new code put it on to this kind of
recording device and stick it in the
machine and it behaves differently based
on that new code so this is the you know
in a way this is the birth of the whole
idea of programmability becomes
thinkable with this device and the kind
of the division between hardware and
software such an extraordinary and a
significant divide in modern life really
comes into focus for the first time with
the instrument that plays itself and
what's even more amazing is that idea of
programmability is kept aloft by music
for 500 or 600 years music boxes start
to appear in Europe where people are
using these little pin cylinders to
program both music and then increasingly
these automatons that were developed
there were these you know kind of
beautifully crafted machines lifelike
machines this is Jacques de volcán song
who designed a number of them in the
beginning the 18th century in in Paris
and these were you know little robots
sometimes music playing robots he
actually had an automated flute player
Vokoun son did he's most famous actually
for a device some of you have seen the
the digesting duck which was as the name
suggests a entirely automated mechanical
dock that you could feed little pellets
of food to and you can see it actually
goes through the
the Ducks innards and then it's excreted
out in some kind of digested form at the
end of the process this was the great
kind of marvel of Paris and that kind of
salons of Paris is that the defecating
digesting duck that's what the kids were
into back in the day a fairly and vocal
some was very interested in these things
anyway it's been a lot of time thinking
about cylinders thinking about pin
cylinders and and how to control the
kind of machinery but at some point in
this process he starts to think well
wait a second what if we could use a pin
cylinder not to play music and encode
music but what if we could use it
actually knock board or to control a
duck but actually could use it to weave
fabrics and so he begins to sketch out
this idea for a mechanical loom where
the patterns in the fabric would
actually be encoded in these big pin
cylinders and he builds a couple of
these on the problem is the cylinder is
one are very expensive to produce oh if
you want to change your your pattern and
it's really difficult and the patterns
by definition have to be incredibly
repetitive because it's just a endless
loop of this this cylinder and so the
idea really never takes off but a couple
of his models stick around in museums in
Paris where 50 years later jacquard
stumbles across broken stones original
designs and begins to think that maybe
there's a way of taking this idea of
encoding instructions for a machine to
make textiles but using a different
mechanism not pin cylinders not big
metallic devices but paper punched paper
cards and that becomes the famous
jacquard loom which is a revolution in
textile production of course but it
leads directly to Babbage's Charles
Babbage's analytical engine and
Difference Engine the first true kind of
programmable computers ever really
envisioned that were programmed in part
with paper punched cards and in fact
punch cards many of you will remember
continued to be a part of modern
computers until the 70s I remember them
from dating myself but I remember them
for Mike in a third-grade class when we
the school first got its you know one
computer we had I remember seeing punch
cards there
and there's actually as it turns out a
very long and rich and an amazing
connection between the history of
computation and the history of music and
why that is is a whole interesting
question there's something about music
that lends itself naturally to being
encoded but just think about something
like the keyboards we use with our
computers think about dependent you are
we they're not it's you know sexy is
most of the technologies we use today
but think how important an alphanumeric
keyboard whether it's an actual
traditional keyboard or or one that we
use on a screen and a virtual keyboard
think how important that is to the
modern digital age how much time all of
us spend typing in in one fashion or
another and how hard it would have been
to program our machines to do anything
had we not had keyboards but keyboards
originally in the form of typewriters
are one of those inventions that
actually arrived
strangely late on the scene and that's a
little bit like the bicycle they just
seem to have been invented too late we
didn't really actually have typewriters
until the 1880s but we had keyboards
musical keyboards for 2,000 years before
that the Romans had organ keyboards they
had hit upon the idea a 2000 years
before of actually using all that kind
of ten digits of your hands
simultaneously potentially to encode or
perform or share information in the form
of musical notes and musical keyboards
had survived from organs to clavichord
xand harpsichords to pianoforte z' and
pianos for all this long period of time
where was clear that there was utility
there in being able to simultaneously
play music with your fingers but for
some reason nobody took the leap to
translate that over into typewriters and
eventually into the keyboards of of our
computers until 1870 1880 when people
start to a tinker around with this idea
and in fact the very first typewriters
the very first typewriter that we would
recognize that the typewriter was called
the musical harpsichord and the word key
and keyboard is an echo of that original
musical sense of the word key so take a
step back then and think about all the
ingredients that were required to
invent a computer a modern computer a
programmable computer with the keyboard
the conventional way that we think about
this story is that computers
particularly in the modern age came out
of big military developments they came
out of people trying to calculate rocket
trajectories or to try and break the
enigma code or what what you know a
whole series of things and also then
quickly became part of big institutions
whether government bureaucracies or big
corporations and that is in fact part of
the story that's an important part of
the story and I don't mean to
shortchange it but it's also essential
that we remind ourselves that it also
took some other crucial ingredients that
played a defining role in the in the
beginnings of these ideas that it took
automated flute players and beautiful
patterns woven out of cloth and
pianoforte keyboards and and
harpsichords those were part of the
story as well and if we only tell the
story of that invention that innovation
of the programmable computer in terms of
the military history in terms of the big
business history we miss that crucial
thread of delight which is also part of
the tale and I'll tell you then
one final set of stories about the
history of delight and and and involves
really shifting our understanding of
what innovations are right we think
about innovation in terms of technology
and devices and so on but I think it's
just as important to remember that there
sometimes situations were just kind of
redefining places and thinking about the
spaces we inhabit or creating different
kinds of institutions that's a crucial
kind of innovation as well that we
should be celebrating along with the
devices and one of the things that we've
we've seen over the last several
thousand years is a proliferation of
spaces
specifically designed buildings rooms
specifically designed for the pursuit of
kind of amusement and and and leisure
and hanging out and having a good time
non-functional spaces and maybe some of
the original ones are the kind of the
first taverns and bars those are places
where people gather together just to
have a drink it was not home it
was not worked was that kind of classic
in a third place and this is an old old
innovation right we've we've had taverns
and bars since before Roman times but
they have played a crucial role in the
history of democracy and the history of
political revolt in the history of new
subcultures fighting for people's
freedom bars and taverns have played an
essential role in history you cannot
tell the story of the American
Revolution without the network of
taverns in the American colonies this is
the the Green Dragon tavern Inn in
Boston the taverns were the places where
things like the Declaration of
Independence were read aloud where
common sense was read aloud where these
new kind of seditious ideas were shared
just as in the century before coffee
houses had been so crucial to new ideas
a new political kind of potentially
sedition in Europe particularly in
London these are crucial spaces now it
is entirely possible that in the
American Revolution would have happened
had there not been any taverns that is
probably true but what is clear is that
it would have required a completely
different information network and social
network for the ideas and the movements
to develop the tavern was an essential
part of that story and just think about
the importance of taverns
in things like the gay rights movement
then black hack Tavern in bar in Los
Angeles the Stonewall Tavern in New York
it's it's no accident that those were
places where people gathered together
for the first time they weren't at home
they weren't at work there was a place
of kind of leisure there were some
drinks involved and new forms of human
connection and social identity could be
formed so those spaces are really
crucial ones in our history and and they
seem initially to have no real you know
immediate function but they end up
unlocking new forms of possibility new
forms of identity that weren't visible
before they came around and the other
kind of space that came out of this
history of delight that I think is
really important to to remind ourselves
that a bit too is kind of a creation is
the space of nature itself because until
the late 1700s and early 1800s
in in the cities and agricultural areas
of places like Europe nature raw nature
was strangely conceived of as a threat
and actually is aesthetically kind of
repulsive there was this really
interesting kind of sensibility where
people were just offended visually by
things like mountains there's this kind
of crazy literature you read through
where people were just appalled at these
kind of monstrous forms on the horizon
so they when they would be carried you
know by coach by the Alps they would ask
to be blindfolded so that they didn't
have to see these horrible creatures
looming and which kind of makes sense in
a sense you've been you know you finally
escaped from nature and you've kind of
made your way into the city and so
nature is the thing that might kill you
and so you want to be away from it as
much as possible and so we developed
this strange almost kind of anti by bio
phobia almost to twist Gio Wilson's bio
philia but then slowly thanks in part to
kind of scientists particular with
mountains there's this kind of
interesting movement towards
mountaineering and kind of conquering
the Alps it develops in the seventeen
hundreds and then in the eighteen
hundreds romantic poetry and romantic
painters begin to celebrate this kind of
rugged natural look and we begin to have
a different attitude towards unfiltered
nature and people begin to think of
doing things like the vacationing in the
mountains suddenly becomes something
that you didn't sound immediately crazy
and all of these interesting little
devices developed to support this new
interest and one of them was called the
the Claude glass and this is this is a
beautiful little creature it was
basically a mirror and people would take
a Claude glass with them on their trip
too into you know kind of raw nature and
the mirror basically they had all these
little small edges on it so that it
created the effect of the kind of
cracked look and so they faded look of
an oil painting and so people would go
to you know visit the Alps and they
would get there and they would turn or
and look at the mountain in this claude
glass device which would make it look
like an oil painting by some great
Romantic artist so it was a it was an
Instagram filter they just they just
didn't realize it at the time and that
that process of kind of reimagining
nature is a space that we should be
enjoying then leads to the idea that we
might want to preserve some of these
spaces and out of that transformation in
our understanding of nature and the
value of nature we get the National
Parks movements Yosemite Yellowstone and
so on and now the world is filled with
all these natural parks national parks
state parks think about the incredible
natural beauty that's preserved around
this great city comes out of that shift
in our understanding of nature as not
being something to be feared or
disgusted by but rather something to
delight in and to play in and that also
creates the possibility of a new kind of
Wonderland an urban Wonderland of city
parks and this too is one of the great
inventions really of the last several
hundred years the idea of these planned
spaces inside of our great cities
devoted exclusively to leisure and
recreation that belonged to everyone
there were true democratic institutions
that were not just the kind of exclusive
parks where the leader the aristocracy
were allowed to roam private parks but
these were parts that belong to everyone
in the middle of these crowded city
centers that have been deliberately
sketched out this is Prospect Park near
where I live in Brooklyn the other grade
Olmstead Park in New York City and these
these parks are really extraordinary
inventions that we should be celebrating
along with the you know the iPhone and
the Internet it's something that we now
really unfortunately I think take for
granted in too many cases but they're
really miraculous creations and they are
celebrations of delight and and play and
Wonder and the idea that those spaces
can
belonged to anyone in a great teeming
city that too is a real radical advance
and one that I think we should remind
ourselves of more often if you go to a
place like Prospect Park I took this
picture myself on your average say
fourth of July and this was taken in the
early spring but go there on a fourth of
July and just look around and what's
happening in this space it's worth
reminding ourselves particularly at this
moment in time in this political moment
in time here's what you will see there
on that 4th of July is all of the
cultures of the world gathered together
in this shared space hanging out playing
frisbee listening to music grilling some
hotdogs walking their dog and he did
some really rare and precious kind of
achievement it's funny when we think
about kind of classic 4th of July
iconography in the United States what
always comes to mind is that kind of
small-town look of the you know that
kind of small town with the white picket
fence and the patriotic bunting and the
and the firetruck and the little kids
out but in a way that experience is an
old one human history is filled with
small communities knowable communities
where everybody looks like and and
there's a kind of shared identity
everybody knows your name what is much
rarer is the achievement that we see in
public spaces like this one where you
have hundreds of different nationalities
and languages sharing a space together
goofing off and getting along that is a
real breakthrough that is a real
achievement and I hope that's one of the
things that we can remind ourselves in
this day and age and it's sense it is a
it is a process it is an experience that
began with those cloves and those spices
thousands of years ago
slowly weaving the world together
through long periods of devastation and
and suffering and you cannot tell the
story of delight and play and wonder
without telling stories about the you
know slave trade and and cotton in the
United States and long periods of human
suffering but the part of the result of
that
newly connected world thanks to these
intriguing new spices and fabrics from
around the world is is this a play land
of people from everywhere gathered
together at peace with itself and at
play thank you very much thank you he
talks so fast and so densely than none
of you wrote questions write some more
questions bring him down to Kevin Kevin
will bring him up to me and we'll carry
on one whole area in your book that
there wasn't time for tonight but now
there is is what you draw from games in
the history of games and all of that in
this regard well I'm glad you asked
about that because you are a character
in that part of the book sure that
wasn't why you asked but so it's another
side of the history of computing that's
really interesting is how important in
addition to music how important games
are to the history of computing and one
of my favorite stories in the book
actually and I went back to the Computer
History Museum down in Menlo Park and
experienced this firsthand with my son
is the story of the game space war which
you play a role in and space for was
this get really the first true kind of
thing that we recognized as a video game
that was created in 1961 by a bunch of
we would call them now hackers from MIT
and they had this new extraordinary
computer that had a monitor this was the
big breakthrough and so they were trying
to figure they can show graphics I was
the pdp-1 and they they were trying to
figure out what we've got this monitor
like what are we gonna do with that and
they were like well what if we created a
game a kind of a space-themed game and
so they created this game which is
really the antecedent of asteroids if
some of you remember asteroids and this
thing kind of takes off and you could
make the argument it's one of the most
important piece
of software written in the 60s because
it kind of develops open-source style
through through the 60s and this code is
passed around and all these innovations
start happens one of the first examples
where you see an avatar representing
yourself on the screen that you can
control so it's a predecessor in a way
of a kind of a mouse icon and so on or a
pointer there's also one of the early
pushers of time sharing because they
were trying to make these big basically
mainframe and then so-called many
computers act like a personal computer
and people would add all these features
to it like one guy created this program
called expensive planetarium which
recreated the night sky accurately so
one of the first times in any kind of
non-military application you had actual
realistic renderings of reality on a
computer screen again for no purpose
what they've actually added nothing to
the game whatsoever it was just stars
kind of in the background and what it
then eventually it it kind of you know
it's one of the first in a sense of
open-source software projects as well so
all these ideas that become crucial to
computing develop out of it but then one
of the things that happens is this kid
Stewart Brand goes and organizes that
space for Olympics at Stanford and
writes about it for rolling stone and
through watching these people with this
you know rapturous relationship to this
game on the screen he begins to think
you know compute as these rights
computers are coming to the people and
then the next line of that article is
that's the best news since psychedelics
because it was 1972 whatever so here you
have this game and yet it ended up
playing a really kind of defining role
in in the history of computers in that
period how about chess things like that
Google backways there I mean there's so
many kind of stories off a chess there
is this chess it's an interesting thing
because it turns out to be this
incredibly powerful metaphor right it
just is used in so many different forms
obviously it's an accrual kind of
metaphor for thinking about how the mind
works how intelligence works it's
crucial for Turing but the history of
chess as the metaphor is much older than
that there was
there was a book published by a guy
named seselis he had a kind of a number
of different translations of his name
but he published this book it was
actually one of the first books ever
printed it was based on a series of
sermons that he had done in the years
before Gutenberg and I was published I
believe was a second book published in
English after the Bible and it was a
very weird book in the sense that it
doesn't quite have an analogy today it
was kind of a game guide to chess it was
like how to get better at chess and so
you can learn the rules of chess and
learn strategies but it was also a kind
of sociological treatise and so people
in this book seselis would say well the
Queen should behave this way and the
knight should behave this way and also
that is how they should behave in life
and he and he created this whole
elaborate system of describing the
proper rules for people but it was it
was actually really interesting shift
because he was basically making an
argument for a vision of society where
individual people are individual kind of
vocations had their own kind of autonomy
it wasn't the metaphor of like the Kings
body where it's the state is this
unified thing all part of the king
top-down it was a vision of a new kind
of society organized by kind of
contractual relationships between people
and institutions where there was a king
and there is a queen but there was also
this kind of semi autonomy of all these
different players and society would work
if you followed these rules and kind of
lived your own life within the kind of
limits of the rule set of chess and and
of life and so it was popular we think
not just because it was a good guide for
playing chess but because the idea
itself resonated culturally at that
moment of time well this raises a
question Philip raises how does sport
finian is a realm of delight driving the
civilization Sayle any metaphors that
people use businesses for a long time
we're kind of using football metaphors
to talk about you know how they should
compete things like that but what the
hell is sport and how far back does it
go on Olympics and all of that it's very
old the the there's a really interesting
book after was just the emailing with
this guy today of a guy named John Fox
called the ball
that's just all about the history of the
ball as a technology balls are very old
there there there are that's my that's
the takeaway of tonight that weirdly
there are a number of societies where
they developed balls but did not develop
wheels which is a kind of interesting
thing we're like this is really fun but
yeah yeah so but actually there's a one
of my favorite stories there's also kind
of theirs the metaphor sport which I
think is is part of the story
but there's also the interesting history
of material science with sports so on
Columbus's second voyage to the New
World
they're hanging out I think it's off of
my modern-day Haiti I believe it is and
there are these indigenous people there
aren't kind of near the beach and
Columbus's men are hanging out and
they're watching them play this ball
game and they're like what is the deal
with that ball
it is so bouncy like we can't figure out
what is going on it just seems to be
defying gravity like I don't understand
that what they're seeing for the first
time is rubber and so all throughout I
mean this is a because it was a big
ancient kind of innovation of
Mesoamerican society but they basically
had figured out a kind of a low-tech way
to vulcanized rubber
you know many hundreds of years before
Goodyear and they they had done some
functional things with it but the big
thing is they developed this ball game
which took an a legendary ball game that
all those civilizations played and that
was apparently an important part of kind
of religious rites so there's a direct
connection between people who are kind
of so religiously into their football
teams that day worship at the Church of
whatever I know so little about football
now that I can't even make a joke that
it has any specifics to it I'm sorry but
how you follow them I really I've kind
of lost interest in sports but so rubber
rubber they bring back these balls to
Europe and rubber as a material again
it's a little bit like the idea of
programmability in music boxes it it
circulates through Europe for a couple
hundred years purely in the form of
balls before people are finally like
wait I could make a tire out of that
that's pretty good and it says there are
all these amazing descriptions people
like I can't believe it you throw it
down and it just seems to pop right up
it's so crazy something you've left out
off of your books going all the way back
to everything bad is good for you and
we're good ideas come from and now the
role play in making the modern world one
of the great areas of frivolity is
pornography and prostitution yeah
there's only one prostitute in the
current book that I know she was in her
tavern but I know maybe other people are
doing that yeah I can see some problems
with the subject but surely there's a
huge domain of frivolity and non
necessary things leading all sorts of
creative yeah you know I thought that
that is a really good observation and I
may correct that someday but my children
a little older and I'll write that book
it's already bad enough that I wrote
this book defending videogames I'm
already getting so much heat for that
from them but you know I thought about
it a lot with this book and did a lot of
very intensive research no I did
months no I I I ultimately decided not
to do it not to include a chapter
because it was too tied to the
biological urge did the kind of the
grounding of the madness you know and so
so there there there was a line that I
had at some point in the draft which was
basically like that that that
pornography you know maybe a kind of
frill or something like that but but sex
is still a staple on some level and it's
close enough tied to sex that it didn't
make the kind of stronger argument that
the book is trying to make like here are
things that really have no connection to
basic drives and yet nonetheless they
we're so important so that that was one
of the so there's a great book yet to be
written and research not by Steven
Johnson on the passing on Michael MS are
there different flavors of play
constructive destructive collaborative
is there a taxonomy of play there's you
know wising and homo Luden's going to
any of that did you try to sort of do a
taxonomy to play actually kind of the
opposite in this book because and and I
think it's actually been you know one of
the criticisms of it in a way there was
a piece of Steven Poole wrote in the in
the journal that was kind of a mixed
review of the book but his biggest
criticism was that I was grouping
together these things that kind of
didn't belong necessarily together stuff
that didn't fit in the previous book and
and my argument for that is that when we
think about that question I began with
right like what are the prime drivers of
historical change right and our answer
is that so if if you take any of those
if you think like into the quest for
seeking freedom of some kind right
that's a big driver the longer arc of
history expanding personal freedoms
right that is made up of things that are
very different from each other right the
the creation of democratic systems of
governance where you choose your leaders
are free to do that in you're free to
kind of vote them out that as part of it
and
the freedom to have sex with someone of
your own choosing of the gender of your
own choosing that's another kind of
freedom very different acts but we
understand that the idea they kind of
advance of freedom is a big enough
concept that we want to put all those
things under that umbrella and the
problem with play is that we end up kind
of balkanize thinking a lot when we just
say well okay this is this is game play
over here this is fashion over here this
is music over here and when we do that
we we miss the the significance of the
whole kind of landmass and so I wanted
to put them all together under this kind
of broad category that's not a lot of
time to figure out what the word should
be and it's you know there it really is
kind of multiple words but I think there
is there is a big difference
I feel like gameplay is a really
distinct thing and I'm very interested
in this I just I just wrote a piece the
other day that's up on on medium about
it's kind of inspired by the book but
about this experience that I had
designing a board game with my
nine-year-old son who you've met which
was he was 9 at the time this is a year
and a half ago and going through the
process of sitting there and kind of
dreaming up what the game should be and
what the rules should be and it's an
incredibly rich intellectual experience
and it's a great a parenting experience
because you're kind of on the same level
right the kid knows a lot about games
and is very good at figuring out games
and and so you're both kind of experts
or amateurs on the same level and you're
forced to do all these things right you
you you dream up the game you have to
think about probability you have to
think about statistics you have to think
about randomness you have to think about
what the rules should be what the theme
should be and you build this hypothesis
in your head about how this game is
going to work and then you test it you
finally start to play and it turns out
the game is terrible you know like you
yeah it's so boring or you yeah that's
one player will always win after three
turns because it's something you didn't
see and so what you have to start to
think about it's kind of basically
emergent behavior with all these rules
all these interacting parts what will be
the property of the game will it be fun
will it not be fun will be challenging
will it be strategy and so on and once
you've tested it then you revise it and
build a new hypothesis and test it again
and so what you're learning is the
scientific method you know you're
building AI hypothesis about something
testing and revising that hypothesis
based on the feedback from the system
and rinse repeat and that is a really
rich form of thinking and learning and
the beautiful thing about it is your
nine-year-old has no idea that they're
learning right that's the power of it
they're just having fun with dad
so it's a really good thing I mean I'm
not a big like parent advice person but
if you haven't designed a board game
with your kid I would advise you to well
this is sort of the observation that led
to thing I did in the early 70s called
the new games tournament which is that
grown-ups pretty much play games
according to the rules including war and
various other things and kids basically
make up the rules all the time they get
there easily board you screw around you
haven't got the number of people you're
supposed to have for baseball so you
figure out game of baseball is just -
baseball - basis or just a stick instead
of a bat or whatever the hell I may be
or you know you're just goofing away
with a jump roping you figure out
something crazy new things you can do it
then kids just do that automatically and
it's something that we educate out of
them of ourselves and part of the the--
I think surrendered to frivolity and
innovation is to readapt that kid
approach things make up new rules I had
this other thing I've kind of started
this pizza I was mentioning when I was a
kid I went to this phase where I
designed all these dice baseball games
for like two years I charted for those
of you were old enough to remember this
before we had video games I was like in
fourth grade and fifth grade and we used
to have before we had Madden and ps4 and
things like that we we had we would play
these games where you had little cards
representing each of the players and
you'd make your lineup and then you
would kind of roll the dice based on the
results and they figured out the
probability of this batter having a
triple and this batter striking out
versus this pitcher and I played these
games and then I got they weren't
statistically accurate enough for me so
I started designing my own games making
them more accurate and I spent like two
years doing this alone in my room no one
would ever come over to play my house
because they were really they were it
was totally insane it was just me I'm
like yellow legal pads with
numbers on them but but I learned again
I mean it's what I was trying to do with
my son is like I learned a tremendous
amount about building a model in my head
and trying to and just doing math in my
head doing probability in my head it was
really it was an incredible experience
very nerdy but but incredible Ryan feel
ass is the history of pet ownership some
version of play yeah that's a it's kind
of like sports where you put all this
passion to do a thing which isn't human
yeah I hadn't thought about it in that
way but but it's right it is a very
interesting thing and the two things
about it that that come to mind first is
there's a riff in in Wonderland in the
book about about zoos right the
introduction of public zoos right and
and as part of the kind of parks and and
a new kind of sense of nature and one of
the when the London Zoo is formed in the
kind of late thirties it's one of the
first public Jews ever and if not the
first I'm sure it says one of the things
in the book I can't remember there's so
many things in the book but they did
this terrible thing where they had an
orangutan I think it is that they would
dress up in inhuman clothes and and
taught the orangutan to serve tea and
things like this which is you know we
now look at it in we're like oh my god
that's just awful
but Darwin visited the zoo in 1838 and
you know Darwin's kind of famous for
coming up with the theory of natural
selection reading Malthus and you know
his his study one night in 1838 but if
you go back at his Diaries there there
is all this really interesting powerful
stuff that he writes about the the clear
connection between this great ape and
human beings from going and visiting the
zoo and so the introduction of that zoo
is actually a big part of the kind of
the breakthrough of natural selection
even though unfortunately involves this
kind of ridiculous scene of a orangutan
having tea
okay contemporaries can I just say one
more thing to respect sorry I I you know
the question is kind of deeper questions
like why we find delight in things why
we have this appetite for delight and I
was just I was down in Santa Barbara on
book tour and I had this conversation
with John to be the evolutionary
psychologist and and I was asking him
about this it's like what other species
show this kind of sensibility and this
interest in kind of playful behavior and
and there seems to be a very clear
interesting correlation between overall
complexity elegance and play time
particularly in in development and but
one of the things he was saying he said
there there are many cases where people
have observed chimpanzees in nature
going clearly on a distinct walk where
they've gone out of their way they've
left behind whatever they're doing and
they follow a very clear path through
the woods and to arrive at a waterfall
where they then will sit at the
waterfall and just look at the waterfall
for 30 minutes and then they go back and
so they clearly been like oh you know
what I gotta check out and go to look at
that waterfall but I did a little
mindful time by the waterfall you know
and and I thought you know it's funny
because we had in Prospect Park there
was a just embarrassing little waterfall
that they made with like sewage runoff
or something like that but they made in
the in the old-growth forest in the
middle that is otherwise wonderful in
Prospect Park and when our kids were
little we would take them we'd make this
pilgrimage to the waterfall like that
chimpanzee in which they basically were
a couple little trip I'd say and we
would go and look at the waterfall there
was no it wasn't clear like why but it
was just something they lived in a world
where waterfalls were scarce and so
seeing them was somehow interesting and
delightful as sad as this little
waterfall was Michael McClure the beat
poet tells the story of one-time use you
know without and taking one of these
hikes and miring things and you came
across a rabbit was sunset and the
rabbit just sat and watched the Sun set
and clearly delighted the rabbit and
they're really delighted Michaels yeah
Peter Schwartz Aston this is sort of
building on your if you want to see the
future go where people are having a good
time and so Peter asks where is the
frontier of wonder and play today and
what does that tell us about the future
well yeah that I didn't even kind of
talk about that so much in in the talk
there's a kind of predictive component
to play that's pretty interesting you
know if you were trying to figure out
the big changes that were coming to
society if you were sitting there in
1750 trying to figure out what was
coming next watching those automated
machines in the Parisian salons would
have been as good a prediction as any
anything happening in Parliament or in a
battlefield or something like that I
mean there was so much of the future of
automation and technology and artificial
intelligence and computation all was
kind of in its embryonic form there and
so far the idea is when you looking at
what people are doing for fun is a way
of kind of envisioning the future and I
think you know I the clearest case of
this it's almost an obvious one was this
summer with Pokemon go right I mean you
know here you have if if we believe as
many of us probably do that there's some
kind of augmented reality that it's
going to become part of our kind of
day-to-day lives or we're gonna walk
around looking through some kind of
screen at the real world with metadata
attached to it that we had this global
phenomenon where all these people my
kids you know as much as anybody who
were begging to go out for a long walk
for the first time in their entire lives
all those years we said dragging them to
the waterfall suddenly they were like if
they just had talking about go they
would like we got to go to the waterfall
like there's Pikachu there or whatever
and so so we could see this this kind of
glimpse of this future in the form
instead of you know kind of serious
augmented reality was imaginary monsters
that people were capturing but it was it
was the beginning of that Mike Austin s
and in this context do you love or
dislike gamification and why yeah it's a
good question
I think that the problem with and I
wrote about this a little bit and
everything bad it's good for you too
when I was writing about games the thing
the thing about games is that they are
and and this is why designing a board
game with your kid is so great they are
just incredibly addictive forces and so
you can get people to do when in terms
of designing a board game for instance
you can get people to do very you can
get them to think in very rigorous ways
and in a strange sense while they're
doing something for fun because the game
pulls a man and there haven't you know I
was solving all these stupid math
problems designing baseball games
because there was something so you know
addictive about making a great game and
so you can in a sense to use those
forces for good and you can use those
forces for evil and so when you when you
are you know if you are using
gamification techniques where you're
pulling people in and there's some kind
of leaderboard that can be a powerful
thing but it's so easy to abuse it and I
haven't I honestly am NOT an expert in
how it has been applied and so I don't I
wouldn't want to say whether I feel on
the whole if I'm you know kind of a
friend or a foe to it but the capacity
for abuse is it's certainly there so
maybe you following a question from
Kevin Kelly's is there a contradiction
or a danger in the corporate desire to
use play in order to be useful and to
generate Ovid's his purpose will play a
contradiction in some level yeah I mean
I I it's interesting like there I felt
that tension a lot when I was writing
the book because well in the sense that
it was in the section with the
prostitutes I think
it was there there's an argument for
like half of the half of the book and
half of kind of what I was talking about
tonight is in a sense to the kind of the
functional version of play like play
does these things and it enables us to
come up with new ideas it enables us to
push kind of the range of possibilities
that are available to us as a society or
challenge our status hierarchies or
whatever it is and I think that's true I
think that's part of it and that's one
of the reasons why I wrote the book and
why I'm here talking about it but a part
of me also wants to just celebrate that
part of what it is to be human that that
capacity that that desire to go and sit
and look at the waterfall that desire to
sit there and play a game and and have
no other kind of function other than
this is fun and I'm in this great moment
of kind of delight with my friend here
or my kid or whatever it is and and not
make some kind of elaborate argument for
why it's purposeful and a hold that is
kind of sacred a little bit how about
the kind of purposeful placing so you go
to certain companies and there's you
know foosball yeah right there and
there's this like the zoo or the park in
the middle of the city and it's a little
place to go right create in the state of
a create or what I'm just thinking now
I've been to a lot of those companies I
don't think I've ever actually seen
anyone playing foosball you feel a there
even a ball in those games I mean I
would okay all right all right so that's
good
glad to see that they're being used so
so I was just at Etsy and in Brooklyn we
did we have a little podcast by the way
one of the Wunderland podcasts which
steward has been honest it's fun and
we've kind of dove dove into some of
these issues in the present tense the
book is quite historical and one of the
recent episodes we did was on kind of
play at work precise to this question we
went to Etsy in Brooklyn and their new
headquarters which which are lovely and
one of the things that's good I think
have a foosball table they may have a
thing pong table but what they really
have everywhere is our musical
instruments and I guess they have a lot
of like you know indie musicians who
also you know their day job is working
at Etsy as you might expect in Brooklyn
that's the way it is you kind of have to
have an indie band to live there
and so there's actually a record little
recording studio and and there's like a
piano here and there's like a acoustic
guitar here and people are just kind of
picking them up and playing and having
looked and that I thought was really
kind of lovely and particularly someone
who put I play music purely as an
amateur in my own little like kind of
studio and it's one of these great it's
one of the great joys of my life as it's
a kind of a magical space in your life
where you have a great deal of interest
and passion with zero ambition you know
you just love to do it and you don't
care if no one ever hears if your song
has you know never finds an audience
because it's you you're kind of doing
for yourself and I think that that's
Society of play that I think work
environments can be menacwy make the
work environment both more productive
and just a better kind of more humane
place to be which is bringing in
people's hobbies you know it's not about
the unless you are unless your hobby is
playing foosball which is a weird hobby
to have I guess I'm sorry to those of
you or foosball hobbyists
but thinking about you know encouraging
people that have one have a bunch of
different hobbies so all the people that
I've written about over the years you
know one of their defining
characteristics is that they have a lot
of hobbies they just don't think what
Darwin and all Darwin's hobbies are Ben
Franklin and all these people and so
there's a lot of reasons it's suspected
people have a lot of hobbies are more
creative people or their mortgage they
have a lot of different they have a
little kind of diverse mix of influences
and metaphors and tools kind of floating
around in their own mind and their own
interests and they spend a lot of time
focused on their big project but then
they go off and they work on the side
project and something in that side
project escaping from the main project
frees them up to have a new idea that
that ends up changing so I think that
letting people kind of bring their
hobbies in to come share their hobbies
or have a space for them at work I mean
I suppose 20% time
innovation time offered at 3m and Google
and things like that is in a sense a
kind of hobby on the job but even if
your hobby is making you know paper
airplanes or whatever it is so like
bring that in and share it and have it
be part of your life at work I think
that's kind of a nice idea I think
you've got the whole book on the Hobby
here we go somewhere okay that in the
sex book question from be combined
[Laughter]
Charles the big kid asked if childhood
is a modern invention does that mean
play was once something different before
childhood was intended yeah that's a
really that's a really profound question
actually I'd thought about it's
interesting this this book was
originally and may still be a kind of
the basis for a season two of the show
we did how we got to now the last book I
did and it has a similar structure to
how we got sometimes kind of six things
that change the world and and we're
still hoping to make it and one of the
initial ideas I had was that there would
be a long opening chapter kind of on the
invention of childhood itself or the
kind of demarcating of this kind of
period and then when I got in that I did
I didn't get far enough to have anything
useful to say so I'm just gonna make up
some stuff now but what the two things
that we should be kind of clear about
and then I won't say much more be honest
because I really didn't do a lot of
research on this but we did carve out
culturally this long period of childhood
of development of being in school we
invented a bunch of institutions that
clearly did not exist 10,000 years ago
or something like that if not 300 years
ago and so that feeling of like your
period of development and experimenting
and playing has gotten kind of longer
and there's a whole set of institutions
to kind of support that although some of
those educational institutions aren't so
friendly to play is you mentioned
already but human beings in general have
a very long period of of kind of
playfulness
where they just just developmentally are
really interested in play whether the
institutions are there to support them
or not this is just a part of who we are
kind of as the species and I had a great
chat actually this is also in the
podcast with Alison Gopnik
from Berkeley who was talking about this
extraordinary thing the classic you know
fox versus the hedgehog Isaiah Berlin
thing that Philip tetlock has talked
about and the kind of creative
intelligence and problem-solving of the
Fox versus the single-minded kind of
Hedgehog it turns out when you actually
study actual foxes and hedgehogs not in
the metaphors one of the big differences
is that developmentally foxes have much
longer periods of play and so they're
you know they're kind of parents will
will bring kind of dead mice back to
them and kind of toss them in and the
little baby foxes will like play with
the dead mice like a ball basically
they're trying to invent a ball and
they'll have this kind of long period
where they're playing and the idea is
that basically if you're trying to teach
open-ended problem solving where you
know you don't necessarily know what
you're going to confront you got to
think up something on the spot rather
than one solution which is grow stuff up
in a ball like a Chuck doesn't just hope
nobody bothers you then their play is a
great way to rehearse for that it's
about unpredictability it's about
surprise and so creatures that need that
kind of open-ended thinking have long
developmental periods for play as part
of life and humans just have the longest
of all of them
foxes or predators and the hedgehogs are
praying yeah yeah so if you're prey it's
how do I cool up if you're predators
what else can I eat a little in process
so you did this television series it's
horrendously hard to do so I did I did
well it is funny I mean you do all these
things where you just you realize are
all these conventions of a television
documentary where the presenter is just
shown walking around and walking up they
walk up the steps to the office where
he's gonna do the interview and you're
like surely they can figure out that I
walked to this office and then we don't
need to show me actually doing this but
but you know a lot of my work over the
years has been about the power of
collaboration and about kind of
collaborative creative networks and
multidisciplinary thinking and all these
things is the theme of a lot of my books
getting outside of the kind of
individual you know inventor and seeing
kind of innovation is something that
happens in networks it's in you know in
most of the books really and yet why
most of my life I've done a couple of
little startups but most of my life as a
writer it's been very solitary you know
it's a really solitary job you know how
that is you spend a man I mean I don't
use a research assistant anymore because
the internet is so and so replacing jobs
I no no it really it did it absolutely
did I mean I only had one foot before
but the so I spend an immense amount of
time just with me in my own space kind
of sometimes I'll interview people but
mostly it's just me reading and thinking
and writing and and you know widens the
great thing about writing books is that
once they start to get out into the
world the network of people you're
working with gets bigger and then it
gets really big and then it contracts
again which is nice but there's a lot of
solar climb whereas a show is just a to
a fault a very collective enterprise and
you know we had multiple directors we
were collaborating on the scripts we
were you know we had research bunch of
researchers who were helping us find
things we had cinematographers who and
they had all these different fields of
expertise that I knew nothing about
which I nonetheless had lots of opinions
about and and it was it that part of it
was really great it was nice to kind of
then go back to a book and it was nice
to write this one how we got to know we
kind of developed as a book and a show
at the same time which which I think
made for a really nice show and I think
there it it hurt the book a little bit
in my mind whereas I think this because
I wrote it entirely kind of on its own
as a book start to finish it gets a
little bit of a
a better book but it was enough it was
definitely a feeling of I don't I would
never want to do television full-time
that I would like to do it again wow
that's impressive well and look forward
to so those who follow you on twitter
are aware that you are in california by
yourself now just a couple more days
getting going
you're being the solitary writer and i'm
working on a new book very long now book
inspired by us right now know deeply
inspired by like many things that I've
been by by you personally and by a bunch
of people here and by this foundation
it's a book about that I don't think I
have actually talked about in public at
all it's a book about long-term decision
making and well it's basically decisions
that are instead of kind of Blink
decisions got decision system wan
decisions decisions that require
deliberative system one system to Dan
Kahneman Thinking Fast and Slow system
one or your kind of intuitive flash
decisions that you have a lot of kind of
internal algorithms and run in your head
that are biased in various different
ways very helpful but yeah plaintiff
been a lot of Blink the Gladwell book
was about these things and system two is
the slower more kind of contemplative
decision making process or doing yeah
right and so this is really about this
is do thing and it's trying to it's
trying to look at both group decision
making so collective decisions like it
starts with the story about collect pond
in New York which was the source of kind
of fresh drinking water in New York in
Manhattan for centuries and for a couple
of centuries while the Dutch were living
there and then because who was down when
Adam it became a cesspool basically and
there was his people would discard
bodies there and there was
there were tanneries that were set up
there were kind of leeching all the
stuff in the water was just terrible and
so basically around 1800 they were like
what should we do they had this kind of
decision process which really wasn't a
decision at all about what and they
briefly hired lawn fawn to design before
he design Washington to design a park
for this space and likes actually 1790s
done like that and it ended up getting
kind of rejected and so they just filled
it and they built some houses on it but
they did the landfill improperly and so
the biomass began to degrade and stink
and the houses started to sink down and
so everybody left and because of that
that neighborhood became five points
that is the origin of kind of the first
American slum basically was Sarah T if
you think about what that park would be
like it's likely if they built the park
it's probable I mean this is a very this
is like your your point from how
buildings learn about the grid never
changing that part might have lasted for
five hundred years right I mean it's
probably parking potential park will you
know it's entirely likely they might
last for for that long so you can think
of it as kind of like a 500 year mistake
they just kind of filled this in and
created this thing so we actually are
much better at making decisions like
that now we have a lot of techniques for
kind of looking at all the variables
that go into should we build a park here
or should we do this kind of long-term
thing we've gotten much better at that
process we're still not great at it
and we continue as a society to make
some poor choices
but I think which ones but but we do
have we do have a better understanding
of how to do it so I'm trying to kind of
look at there but the other thing about
this book is that it's got literature in
it because part of the argument is
literature I withhold gradual use it
because part of the argument is that in
in personal decisions of that magnitude
one of the great tools that we can use
this is this is one of the kind of
functions of the novel the novels great
novels allow us to kind of rehearse for
the big decisions in our lives and by in
understanding all the variables that are
going and potential consequences of the
big decisions by running all these kind
of parallel simulations of lives that
are vaguely kind of similar to ours or
similar complexity because we don't get
to run parallel simile simulations of
our own lives to see what decisions will
work or not and so literature
in a kind of intimate kind of personal
level lets us do that so there's a
little bit of kind of literature in it
for the first time really any more books
well a book about long-term thinking
will probably lead to another so I'll
talk from you thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]